cher journal j'ai failli mourir et ça ne
choque personne
je me demande s'il existe une étude sur
ces gens qui ont pour mission de nous
prévenir lorsqu une célébrité décède
avant qu'un média traditionnels ne les
devance je n'oublierai jamais que tu
m'as appris la mort de johnny vanessa je
penserai à toi grande journaliste
d'investigation à chaque fois qu'on
passera à allumer le feu en soirée c'est
trop ma chanson par ailleurs je n'en
reviens pas que ton cousin soit passé à
120 kilomètres seulement de l'endroit où
47 personnes viennent de perdre la vie
dans un tragique accident attendant tu
sais qu'à quatre ans oui non c'est pas
vraiment mon cousin c'est le faisant de
la marraine de monde au cours du
deuxième mari de ma tante
tu mérites une page wikipédia vanessa
toi qui es à envoyer tes prières entre
l'australie brelet toi qui défend le tri
sélectif à grands coups de hashtag toi
qui porte le tee shirt de ce groupe de
rock que tu aimes tant et qui a composé
il a composé quoi déjà tu ne te souviens
plus mais c'est pas grave c'est trop ta
chanson tu connais cette théorie des six
poignée de main selon laquelle six
personnes maximum nous séparent de
n'importe qui dans le monde parce qu'on
connaît tous quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un qui connaît quelqu'un qui
connaît quelqu'un tu ne mesure pas qui
tu es vanessa la propre soeur a livré
des sushis à monsieur lavoisier qui
connaît personnellement la femme du
grand docteur petit dont une patiente à
l'occasion d'un meeting en 2012 a serré
la main de nicolas sarkozy
maintenant pense à toutes les personnes
influentes que notre ancien président a
croisé au cours de son mandat
si seulement tu étais au courant et que
tu pouvais en faire une story tu ferais
certainement la une des médias
traditionnels
seule une porte me sépare de mon voisin
de palier il est décédé sur le trône ce
matin et dire que je viens d'aller faire
pipi c'est fou mais ça aurait pu être
moi ça fait froid dans le dos j'ai
failli mourir
j'étais à sa d'apparaître dans la story
de vanessa donc à 6 à des trappes titre
posthume à cette personne de nicolas
sarkozy quand même donc techniquement à
8 personnes de johnny j'étais à sa
d'être quelqu'un d'important en fait
c'est fou comme quoi je tiens vraiment à
rien
[Musique]